>>> KING ABDULLAH OF JORDAN
TODAY.
>> Reporter: YOU WOULD BE
OVEREXCITED TOO, FIJ GETTING AND
IT WAS THE MELANIA AND MET RANIA
SCHOOL.
THEY STOPPED BY ART CLASS AND
SCIENCE CLASS AS THE KIDS
DISSECTED OWL PELLETS, AKA OWL
POP.
THE FORMER MODEL AND THE WOMAN
WHO MADE IT INTO THE BEST
DRE
DRESSED-SITTING IN FRONT ROW
SEATS FOR JOINT PRESS
CONFERENCES, WITH THE KING OF
JORDAN PERCHED ON A BOX FOR
HEIGHT.
>> WE'RE BOTH LEADERS ON THAT,
BELIEVE ME.
>> Reporter: AND THESE TWO EVEN
DRESS ALIKE ONCE IN A WHILE.
WE HAVE HAD BRANGELINA AND
BENNIFER.
WHILE NOT MET RANIA.
THE QUEEN HAS BEEN IN THE PUBLIC
EYE FOR ALMOST TWO DECADES.
>> Reporter: SHE TOLD OPRAH HOW
TERRIFYING IT WAS AT FIRST.
>> THEY'RE LOOKING AT ME, AND
I'M LIKE, ARE THESE PEOPLE FOR
YEAR?
I'M ONLY A KID.
BUT YOU KIND OF GROW INTO THE
ROLE.
>> Reporter: GOOD ADVISE FOR
MELANIA WHO'S BEEN TAKING HER
LICKS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE RELEASED
FIRST LADY MELANIA TRUMP'S
OFFICIAL PORTRAIT TODAY, BUT
SINCE SHE'S NEVER AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, THEY HAD TO GET A LITTLE
CREATIVE.
>> Reporter: THE FORMER MODEL
AND A MONARCH SEEMED
COMFORTABLE, THE FIRST LADY
EVENING TEASED THE QUEEN.
>> YOU'RE VERY TALL.
>> Reporter: QUEEN RANIA OFFERED
TO LOWER HER THRONE, BUT WHEN
YOU'RE BUSY LOOKING AT OWL
PELLETS THROUGH SAFETY GOGGLES,